so I don't normally consider myself to
be a tank video kind of guy and I'm also
very aware of the thing that not
everyone watching this is gonna be a
Doctor Who fan although I do assume that
a fair amount of you are at least today
I actually kind of don't care I just
want to have a massive nerd out so sorry
not sorry who's your favorite doctor
this is how you know it's a serious
Doctor Who tag just going right in with
the most difficult question you can ask
her who fan
it was definitely David Tennant for me
for a long time but then it did kind of
slip into Matt Smith around the time
when I was lucky enough to go behind the
scenes of Doctor Who and meet him and
find out that he'd watch some of my
videos and I gave him a badger puppet
and he named the puppet after me so I do
have this undeniable bias towards him
because of all of that stuff but now I'm
actually really digging Peter Capaldi
like I find his whole like angry old
Scottish doctor thing to be really
refreshing so I don't know that I can
pick so I'm actually going to refuse to
answer this question which is a great
way to start off a tag video I know
what's your favorite Doctor Who story
maybe this is a bit of an obvious choice
but for me it's always going to be blank
I mean not only of the weeping angels
just like the best in that episode they
are so terrifying but I also really love
how small the story feels like I know
Doctor Who is meant to be this like
massive show where like the universe
will be destroyed but for me I just
really love the stories that feel like
little and personal and self-contained
that's where I think the show really
shines for me who's your favorite
companion I feel like I should say Donna
cuz I think she probably is the best
companion the show's over had for many
reasons including the fact that she is
the only companion who's only ever had a
platonic relationship with the doctor
for a change but if I'm honest with
myself I think my favorite is Rory just
because like he's in this relationship
where his wife just doesn't respect him
fully even though he's looked after her
for like 2000 years and then there was
that period where he like died every
single week I just feel so bad for the
guy I just want to give him a hug
therefore he's my favorite what was the
first Doctor Who story you ever watched
episode 1 season 1 of the reboot when
aired on the TV was the first time I had
ever seen the show and I'll be honest
with you I didn't really like it I mean
I get me wrong there is definitely some
really great stuff in the episodes but
then there is also
that terrible cgi-bin that literally
burps when it eats people I mean come on
that was a bit rubbish and so was that
pun but what's your favorite series and
a push I think I'd say series 5 but the
thing about Doctor Who is I don't think
I ever have enjoyed like a whole series
in its entirety before because I find
the quality of the show to just be like
so inconsistent but then again that's
just kind of the way that dr. who is
this might come as a shock actually but
I kind of gave up on the show around
series 7 because it wasn't richest
really wasn't holding my interest
anymore but I did give it another shot
with series 8 because I feel like I have
to try with Doctor Who and it is winning
me back now I have to say what's your
favorite villain or monster I'm gonna go
with a Candyman who is a psychopathic
robotic killing machine made of
liquorice allsorts who likes to murder
his victims by drowning them in boiling
liquid candy because he likes to see
them die with a smile on their faces
he's from an old Doctor Who serial
called the happiness Patrol which is
definitely the worst Doctor Who story
I've ever seen I'm pretty sure the
doctor defeats the Candy Man by like
pouring lemonade on him it's kind of
amazing I did end up skipping a couple
of questions but I hope that's okay
thank you to Luke Spillane for starting
this tank and to Barry Aldridge for
tagging me Barry really didn't seem to
think I was going to do this and so he
said that if I did I could challenge him
to do whatever I wanted so Barry I
challenge you to reenact a scene from
Doctor Who any scene you like and take
as much time as you like to do it
obviously anyone is welcome to do this
if you want to but I'm gonna tag my
friends Liam Rosie and Jack and that's
it for today
Alan Zee you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you very much for watching here's
my previous video about mustaches just
in case you'd like to miss that miss it
no you want to watch it you would have
missed it and now you're gonna watch it
I'm so great at this my new fun science
video about time is still coming it's
just taking a little bit longer than I
planned it to but you'll see it
eventually I promise
and lastly special thanks to Emily for
making me this bow tie I was very loved
you
as if as if it Thank You hour late yeah
there we go
goodbye